in this video i'm going to show you how
to program a smart key
for kia and hyundai that are using this
smart key
right now for this video i'm sitting
inside 2013
kia sportage and what i'm going to do
i'm going to program this key and i will
do it step by step
it's important to mention that
all the vehicles that are using this key
the programming procedure is exactly the
same
one thing that is important to mention
before i start is that in order to
program this key
we must have a security code the
security code ready to go because once
we're going to program the key the
computer will ask us to input the
security code and we must have it ready
so you can get the security code in
different ways
personally i just got it from a code
company you can get it through nastaf or
if you have a different way but you just
need to have it ready for the
programming process at this
a right now this is the security code
that i'm going to use once i program the
key
and it's important to mention that every
key will have its own security code so
this security code will not going to be
for all cars it's just gonna be for this
car
okay so with that being said let's go to
the programming process and let's see
how we do it step by step hi i'm ocean
i'm sorry to interrupt your video i know
it's a pain in the ass but look i wanna
tell you something important i can tell
that you're really interested in
learning about how to program car keys
and remotes well that's what we do in
locksmith videos online so this youtube
channel is just a small fraction of what
we actually do you should really visit
our website at
blacksmithvideosonline.com there you
could find hundreds of videos and
tutorials that will show you step by
step how to program all kind of car keys
and remotes front transponder keys to
remote head keys to smart keys for
vehicles that have a push to start
system and much much more when it comes
to the locksmith field in general and
the automotive field so if you click on
the link below this video or go to
lucksmithvideosonline.com you can have
access to all of the knowledge that i
acquired throughout my 15 years laxmi
career and you can become as
professional as i am on your first day
and on your first try yes i just said it
you can become as professional as i am
on your first day and on your first try
i don't think you can afford to be
without it
okay so the first thing that we need to
do
we need to connect the obd cable adapter
to the obd port which is located
underneath the steering column
okay and once i connect it i can take a
look and see that the lights came on and
that's good indicator meaning that there
is a electricity in the vehicle and now
we can go to the programming process
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so i'm going to turn on the proper
the first thing
and after i turn the proper to the on
position
i'm checking here and i see that the
light the bluetooth light came to blue
that's good sign meaning that there is a
connection between the bluetooth adapter
and the proped and i can start the
programming process
okay so of course before everything i
make sure that i'm in immobilization at
the top track symbol at the bottom and
the bluetooth here is on
and i'm going to choose kia
in the disclaimer i press agree
and in this screen what i'm going to
choose i'm going to choose program
immobilizer or remote
and in this screen i'm going to choose
select from type
and because i'm doing a smart key system
i'm going to choose smart key system
and because i'm in the us i will choose
usa
okay in this screen we have few options
we have type 1 with card slot type 2
with card slot type 3 without card slot
type 4 without card slot so in this
vehicle i do have a programming slot
in the computer call it a card slot so
it have to be between type 1 and type 2.
i don't even know which one is it so
what i'm gonna choose i'm gonna choose
type one and if it doesn't work i will
choose type two so let's start
type one
turn off the ignition switch press okay
to continue the ignition switch the
start button is already off so will
press ok
turn on hazard warning lights press ok
to continue so i will press on the
hazard warning light and we'll press ok
ok right now it did pass to the second
screen so what i'm going to do i'm going
to do program smart keys
and in this screen it gives me different
location where the programming slot can
be
in a
in my vehicle the programming slot
located between the driver side and the
passenger side on the armrest
so a but in different vehicle it's in
different positions so you can check in
your vehicle and see where it is so what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna open the smart
the the the armrest and i take the key
and i just
push it inside the programming slot
until i hear the click i need to push it
all the way this face down
all the way until i hear the click
okay
now when the card is inside i will press
ok
and the
the request was rejected and the status
was incorrect i will press ok and i will
take out
the key from the programming slot
and what i'm going to do i'm going to go
back
and in this option i will choose type 2
with card slot
and i will turn the hazard warning light
off because i'm choosing a different one
and
it tells me turn off the ignition switch
press ok to continue the ignition is
already off i'll press ok
turn on hazard warning lights press ok
to continue so again i'm going to press
on the house of the warning light and we
press ok to continue
fail to connect i will press ok and i
will do it again
and we'll do it again and we press okay
okay and as you can see sometime it
failed to connect but don't worry just
say you can do it again until it get you
to the next line
the next step and if it doesn't take you
to the next step what you can do you can
disconnect the machine
the obd and connect it again and start
the whole process from the beginning
sometime cars and computer react this
way and we just need to live with that
so in this screen what i'm going to
choose i'm going to choose program smart
keys
and again it tells me the different
location that the programming slot can
be so we need to insert the key to the
programming slot so what i'm going to do
i'm going to open the armrest
and i take the a program in
the the smart key i need to push it in
to the programming slot so that's what
i'm going to do now
okay push it in until it click and what
i'm going to do i'm going to press ok
and right now i need to input the
security code
remember that i have the security code
ready in this car is 366 906
okay so let's put it in
six 366.
nine
o
six
and i'll press done
okay the computer tell me a program
success whether to program next one
press yes to continue press no to return
i will press no because i just want to
program one
and please exit system check the smart
key if programmed or not i'll press ok
and what i'm going to do now i will
turn off the hazard warning light and i
will click the pro the the key
in and it will take the key outside of
the programming slot and what i can do i
can test the key
and the key is not a responding yet but
don't worry what i can do i can press on
the break and on the start stop engine
and it's not responding yet but that's
okay
what happened is that sometimes when you
program a new key for kia or hyundai
it's take a few moments until the
computer realize that the key is
actually programmed so what i can do i
can just disconnect
the machine
[Music]
and
press on the brake and try to start the
engine and as you can see the engine
just started
so
basically
if this situation happened to you one
moment
i will turn it to the off position and
now i can check the remote
lock
unlock
unlock and basically that's it the keys
program and
if this situation happened for you
that can happen sometimes take few
moments until the computer realize that
the key is actually programmed and
sometime you also need to disconnect the
obd cable adapter before the car can
actually start the engine so in your car
you will see what you need to do but
don't get panic this situation sometimes
happen and basically that's how you
program a smart key
for a kia or hyundai that's using this
smart key and basically that's it for
this video you want to know how to
program car keys and remotes for all
type of vehicles and easily well if you
do then i have the perfect solution for
you hi my name is moshe and i'm the
owner of a locksmith company for over 10
years i'm an expert when it comes to
program car keys and remotes i created a
website full of videos and tutorials
that will guide you step by step how to
program all kinds of car keys and
remotes by using this website you will
be able to program all kind of car keys
from your first day and from your first
try from transponder keys to remote head
keys to smart keys for vehicles that
have a push to start system all you will
have to do is just go to the search bar
and type the make here and model of the
car that you would like to program the
key for then choose the correct video
from the suggested videos and follow the
video step by step it's that easy and if
you would like to order the exact same
key that is being explained in the video
no problem just press on the link at the
bottom of the description and you can
order the exact same key that is being
explained in the video it's that easy go
to
www.luxmitvideosonline.com and see it
for yourself
[Music]